speaking of maximizing your brain
let's talk drinks all right now it is
that we're celebrating back to school
week here on las vegas now it's our last
day so we cannot forget about the
parents and the adult students right so
andy hooper from el duchadore is here to
tell us how you can find your you know
stressful monday you can cure it with a
spicy margarita
of something or something of that nature
right um we're here to cure the monday
blues well nothing takes care of the
monday blues better than tequila
do you have kids are you i do yes yes my
son will be back in school soon so uh
i've been lucky to be able to enjoy
these margaritas all summer long so
monday tuesday wednesday i usually enjoy
them but the special for us is on
mondays where we provide five dollar
margaritas all day long all night long
yes oh my gosh okay so
it's a party at a luchador what is the
vibe like
you know when when the parents and the
adult students come in after after a
hard day fun
okay it's all based on wrestling so it's
all about lucha libre the mask yes of
course we encourage you over there
there you go
rick flair my man uh yes
so we uh we we always have a lot of fun
we encourage people to come in and just
have a blast uh all of our food is made
by lorena tells an excellent excellent
chef she's uh she's been with us for
about two months now amazing and then
all of our tequilas and margaritas and
and mezcals are are very low sourced uh
very rare to get you know
80 tequilas and mezcal whoa i heard that
you know all the tequila snobs and you
know the picky ones they're they're
usually very satisfied when they come to
luchador so yeah let's get into the
specialty margaritas okay especially
margaritas so you know i'm going to show
you how we make our number one specialty
margarita which is our mango habanero
margarita ooh that sounds cool so we
take silver tequila and we put it in
mangoes and habaneros for about three
weeks so it gives us this great color
tip there all you know all the fruit is
in there so and and the worst thing
about this or the best thing about it
right
is that is that it does not taste like
tequila so it is extremely
dangerous i was gonna say that sounds
dangerous so and the way we do it in at
a luchador is we pour two and a half
ounces of tequila which is almost twice
the amount of tequila that comes in a
regular cocktail oh wow okay well let's
get to pointing because i don't want to
run out of time all right yeah so i'm
going to do two and a half ounces in
here so there's
two ounces
and then i'm going to turn it over and
do another half ounce good
all right and then we're going to do a
half ounce
of
organic agave syrup
wow organic guys okay yep oh yeah top
notch oh yeah classy
yes yes
so yes was that a wrap
look here rocky i want you to shake okay
so make sure it's got a good seal on it
oh god there you go
you don't want it everywhere all right
all right there we go there yeah
good
sega tickets that's beyonce right there
i i know you were i know i know don't
make me laugh
and shaking at the same time
okay here you go perfect we're going to
take that off we're going to pour it in
here with our tahini rim oh my goodness
and let you taste okay now while i drink
tell everybody how they can make
reservations or the locations you guys
have so people can visit for their
course two locations one in mountains
edge on the west side at blue diamond
and buffalo the other one is over in
henderson stephanie in warm springs make
reservations at our website
luchadorlv.com
or you can go to open table or rezzy to
make reservations at either of the
restaurants
this is delicious
this is so good wow cheers
i got shots for you jc right here